has anybody taping my show because my
career is over if that's a good
what do you do for a living bro you work
for make-a-wish
get the [ __ ] out of here make a wish no
[ __ ] these
retards want to do [ __ ] before they die
the guy yo he's making that [ __ ] happen
[Laughter]
oh man what do you do do you carry them
to their wish what's your job
you plan it what's the craziest
make-a-wish you got
if a kid wanted anything sexual because
you make that happen
the playboy mansion without the girls
i want to go to the grocery store just
take out all the food
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
that's a real estate tour what are you
talking about
playpoint mansion that kid died unhappy
as [ __ ]
yo that's the worst death i ever heard
in my life
kid got cancer he gotta go meet [ __ ]
hugh hefner
did you at least prep him that there's
gonna be no [ __ ] at this
this thing hey oh we're gonna make a
wish and then he just walks and he just
hears the squeak of his wheels and he's
going through the house
and he's [ __ ] hello hello
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey timmy i'm hugh hefner
that's it nobody's dream is to meet hugh
hefner
unless they're a [ __ ] creep yo that's
creepier than wanting to meet the girls
is one be like no i want to be the guy
who exploits the girls that's [ __ ]
what kind of me too baby is this
you guys might have created a me too if
he pulled out of his
thing because that happens sometimes
they make a wish and then they pull
through
now do you guys ask for a refund in
those cases are you like hey
[ __ ] we paid for a trip to
disney world we thought you were gonna
die dog you owe us about four thousand
dollars
you think it's easy to get that picture
with mickey cut the lines all over
[ __ ] disney world
you get your money back if a kid pulls
through do you need to verify that he
got some [ __ ]
you don't ask for proof at least
what if i got a kid and obviously he's
gonna know a lot of doctors
but if he just pours the documents
nothing y'all could do huh my kid gonna
get a [ __ ] harry potter world trip
and i'm gonna be there with him on every
ride no i missed chapel one
you want to go to gringott's bank again
let's do it
man that's a cool job though seriously
you make a lot of [ __ ] kids happy for
a little bit
what's up guys thanks for watching the
video if you're a fan just hit subscribe
stop hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming after warranty
[Music]
you